Kilda two weeks on from lockdown just
checking in with you and those in your
bubble to see that you're doing okay a
few things to update you on last week I
talked about the coming rates
installment we understand that people
are facing an uncertain financial future
if you have any concerns about paying
this please be in touch with us we have
many options that we can look at to
support you including deferral and we
welcome that opportunity to discuss that
with you and tailor a package directly
to you that will help you through this
period last week council's Emergency
Operations Center was stood up the whole
purpose of this is to support people
through this time in connect you with
relevant organizations so if there's
anyone that you know of that needs
support including yourself please be in
contact with us our numbers oh eight
hundred nine six five four six eight is
a site we're here to help is myrin
counselors we're concerned about the
rates for the coming years and we've
asked our staff particularly in these
uncertain times to have another look at
our budgets and identify where they can
be savings next week we're having a
workshop we will be discussing these
four staff and then in the coming weeks
expect to be able to communicate with
you our thinking we're coming in to
Easter or they'd like to say to you is
make sure that you enjoy the long
weekend take the opportunity to spend
that time with those in your bubble can
eat with your families do you stay calm
please stay home follow the rules be
kind and take care of each other
Happy Easter
you